majesty queen
elizabeth asseko honda est morte à hope
a laissé mais un peu tard et zabeth
seconde très vite l'émotion saisi
l'angleterre les journalistes
britanniques se mettent à porter du noir
à l'antenne les drapeaux sont mis en
berne et les membres de la famille
royale atterrissent en urgence toute la
famille se rassemblent la au chevet de
la reine absente de plusieurs réunions
officielles ces derniers mois l'état de
la reine d'angleterre semble se dégrader
peu à peu oui il ya une fraîcheur
on est
elizabeth 2 c'est finalement tête un tir
hier soir à l'âge de 96 ans et son fils
chaou devient donc le nouveau roi
d'angleterre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est vrai que le monde entier a réagi
dont dans le maniema croquis a fait une
allocution en anglais alors vous avez
fini pourquoi il l'a fait en anglais
parce que il est quand même président d
alors français
pour être compris en angleterre non non
on met des sous titres pop nommé que le
président français s'exprime en anglais
respect pour le peuple britannique et
tout le commonwealth non sur ce très bon
bein ouai ouai commonwealth vous savez
ce que c'est mais bien sûr c'est
l'ensemble des pays qui ont prêté
allégeance à la couronne d'angleterre
pour annuler en fait oui oui béatrice et
américaines oui est ce que cette
nouvelle vous touche particulièrement vu
que les jeux ne sont pas dans le
commonwealth
oui ça m'a attristé c'est vraiment la
fin du jeu n'est pas appréciée ça
m'attriste énormément gt gt mûrissait
c'est j'ai connu qu elle évidemment
comme la 90 % de la population alors à
port de den broeck et koné
mais c'est vrai que je trouve que on en
fait peut-être évidemment il fallait lui
rendre hommage et fait il faut faire ce
qu'il faut il faut en parler de stars je
pense qu'on en fait un petit peu trop
c'est quand même c'est pas notre
histoire et je pense que ces symptômes
étant c'est un peu le prix quand même
aussi l'histoire du monde c'est
l'histoire de l'europe mais ce n'est pas
l'histoire de la france on doit en
parler mais peut-être pas pour ne faire
que par l'état pendant c'est quand même
ce cas là elle était la deuxième guerre
mondiale et tous
deux cherchent ils à isaïe le web
qu'elle a connu à ce moment là jusqu'à
macro maintenant tous les ans c'est la
fatalité elle est restée toujours digne
elle est restée toujours à sa place
toujours défendre le peuple te salit
elle a été quand même exceptionnel il
faut lui l'a fait je crois au combat
après mail a fait une erreur je crois
dans tout son parcours par les goûts
c'est quand la princesse diana c'est
tout elle a tout de suite parlé
prochaine tous les cas le président m'a
qu on lui a rendu hommage en anglais
let's go for de vidéos
aujourd'hui nous sommes tellement triste
it is with great soul the french people
have learned the death of matchstick
queen elizabeth 2 secondes
she was you queen
tu as she was the queen au
kiwi oiseau
a dit saad mohammad azad or heartgold
condoléances tourisme majesty's king de
voir une femme née the british people
[Musique]
nous sommes avec vous
nous sommes vingt minutes dès maintenant
un peu plus on peut dire god save the
king ont dégoté de clearing ont changé
ils ont changé l'hymne bursa c'est
incroyable ça vous allez à la tâche un
attachement particulier pour la france
parce que c'est le seul pays où elle est
venu cinq fois la montée 5 faudra t d
anne parle du palais de parler
couramment français couramment clair
près de gaulle oui oui j moi ce qui me
gêne un tout petit peu quand même c'est
qu'il ya un traitement bien entendu
c'est un deuil mondial ok mais il ya un
traitement très people c'est à dire que
comme si c'était quasiment notre reine
voilà qu'on n'a pas droit à la dren lui
et moi ce qui me gêne quand même c'est
qu'on est loin des préoccupations de la
vie quotidienne des français comment y
revenir je trouve non meilhan qu'un
religieux dans l'odre père ou là les
quelques jours si j'ai les dramas si
l'on met entre parenthèses le temps du
deuil quinze jours qu'un jour
je dis attention à ça que c'est loin des
gens c'est notamment loin des jeunes
aussi attention à ça et comme dirait
cbd est désolé merci beaucoup